hi everyone my name is Jan Freiburg and
I work at a company called Element AI
and I'm here today to talk to you about
active learning in the interactive
Python ecosystem I work at element AI
which is a Canadian startup based in
Montreal and we build products based on
artificial intelligence in general and
in my team products for AI for good in
particular so applying machine learning
and artificial intelligence to problems
that NGOs or other sort of organizations
that are tracking things like abuse
online are doing and so for example we
work on finding abuse online on Twitter
we had a big project about misogynistic
abuse on Twitter we're working a lot
with satellite data on spotting
destruction in particular in Sudan and
we also work with organizations like
forensic architecture which is a group
at Birkbeck University on accountability
and weapons so we're tracking these
teargas canisters in the bottom right
for example in online media mostly using
computer vision and natural language
processing and I work on the computer
vision side so most of the examples
today will probably be based on on
computer vision yeah and so just to give
a quick outline of the talk most of it
will be around acquiring labels for your
data and doing so efficiently how to do
it in Python because this is a Python
conference and then how we can scale
that a little bit and I've been
interested in this for a while I'm
interested in interactive computing in
general and active learning in
particular because when we do projects
like this we often need labels and those
labels are often provided by volunteers
and so the more efficiently we can do it
the better so I'll quickly talk about
why we should label data and so in
general I'm sure most of you were
familiar with this sort of dichotomy and
machine learning between unsupervised
and supervised machine
learning in unsupervised machine
learning we kind of train infrastructure
in the data and so we see where the sort
of modes of the data are where we can
find clusters and we'll use that to them
group data and data points into clusters
whereas with supervised machine learning
if we have some information about the
data such as the which points are blue
and orange here on the right then we can
use that to build classifier models for
example and dividing the data into these
two but that means we need labels right
we need to actually know which of these
points are blue and which of these
points or unsure at least which subset
of these points are blue and orange in
order to be able to train our model and
so labeling data really is moving from
this unsupervised paradigm to supervised
machine learning there are lots of
reasons to do that it's supervised
machine learning can be a lot more
powerful than unsupervised machine
learning and in particular if you
already know that you want to classify
data into specific groups rather than
let an unsupervised algorithm find
clusters or groups of the new data then
you ideally want to end up in this
supervised machine learning paradigm but
labeling data can be expensive it can be
difficult and it can be slow as well and
for those of you who here in the talk
just before it was a geophysicist
talking about acquiring label data by
actually drilling down into the earth
so obviously that cuts costs a lot of
money and it takes a lot of time and
really what we want to do is do this
efficiently because ultimately labeling
data is also essential and it's very
important for a lot of people's work and
maybe just as an example for this I do a
lot of computer vision and so one of the
seminal papers in this is this paper
that first showed state of the art
performance of neural networks on
computer vision tasks and that was done
on the image net challenge which
probably a lot of you are familiar with
it's a huge data set of images which
were labeled by people classifying them
into what is actually depicted in the
image and there are hundreds of
thousands of these and it took a huge
amount of work to produce that data set
but now that we have it we can
mark algorithms against it and we can
train these new state-of-the-art models
that make use of those labels so
labeling data is pretty good cool but
given that it's slow and can't be
expensive you might have to pay people
to actually sit there and label your
data how can we do that efficiently and
hopefully from the title of the talk you
know that I want to sell the idea of
active learning to you so in general the
labeling data process looks a bit like
this you get some people to label your
data and then you train a model and
maybe check the models performance and
if you want to improve your performance
then maybe you label some more data and
you kind of go around until you reach
either the end of your labeling budget
or you've sort of achieved the
performance that you wanted to achieve
and are happy with that cool so the
active learning circle adds a few
elements to this so in active learning
we usually start by labeling some data
just as before and we then also train a
model on this label data so just as
before and that means we can also
benchmark it see how it performs and see
whether they were satisfied with it but
then we actually use the model that
we've just trained to start making
predictions on the rest of the data that
we haven't yet labeled so in the case of
images if we've labeled you know 10% of
our images already we use the model that
we trained on that 10% to make
predictions on the remaining 90% and
then we use those predictions to create
ranking of that unlabeled data and that
ranking is really sort of the priority
in which we want to to label that data
and the real sort of benefit in this
comes from the fact that when we rank
the data using the predictions of a
model we can try to select the data that
will be most informative to the model
and hopefully will most improve our
model so because the model is sort of
telling us a little bit about what it
interprets the data to be we can use
that information in order to provide
maximal information to the model and
then we keep going around so we then go
take that ranking send the top
maybe 10% to our labelers get them to do
some more labeling and then keep going
no the ranking is not manual so and I'll
talk a little bit about that in a second
just to sell you maybe on the commercial
case of this we at element a I work a
lot with image data and in some of the
cases we've sort of reduced the amount
of images that we need to label in order
to achieve the same performance of our
classifier from ten thousand to four
thousand or from seven thousand six
hundred to three thousand six hundred
images and so with active learning you
buy one label and you get one free
because you're reducing the labeling
load by half in some cases so it's a
really powerful commercial tool and in
the case of air for good it means that
you have to use less of your volunteers
precious time to produce labels cool so
how do we actually do the labels like
your question how do we actually get the
ranking of the data based on a model so
imagine that we've got some data that
already has some labels so here we've
got points which are either green or red
and we've already got two labels we've
got one point of here which is red and
one point down here which is green and
we want to classify the remaining points
and because this is a fairly simple
problem and we've only got two features
X and y we can actually fit a fairly
simple model and in this case I've just
drawn a model in the middle of this and
so now what we want to do is basically
choose the data points about which the
model is the most uncertain right so we
have a point up here to the right and
the points close to it are probably more
likely to also be red than the points
very far away from it and likewise the
points in the bottom left are more
likely to be green and so ideally what
we want to choose as points about which
we actually all about which the model
currently doesn't know very much so we
want to choose the points about which
the model is uncertain and with this
fairly simple model is pretty
straightforward we can just choose a
point that's close to the decision
boundary of the model right so this
point in the middle we actually know
that the model if it if the point was
shifting just a little bit to the right
then the model would have classified it
as red
at the moment it's classifying it as
green really we know that the model is
fairly uncertain about this data point
and so that's how generate the ranking
we choose the points about which the
model is uncertain and then we get a
label for that point so now we know that
this is a red point and we've retrained
a model and we've shifted the decision
boundary right so now we have a new
model which hopefully does a little bit
better than the previous model and we
can now repeat this process because now
we have a new decision boundary which
cuts the data in a different way and we
can choose points based on that decision
boundary again so in this case we label
that point it turns out to be a green
point we're shifting the decision
boundary again because we're retraining
the model and so now we've got a very
different looking model to the one we
had before and we select two points
which are hopefully useful to the model
and they've in fact shifted the decision
boundary by quite a lot and we can then
keep going with this and repeat it until
we reach the performance that we want so
that's the general idea it's very easy
to draw out on paper like I've done here
but in many cases we don't actually know
the decision boundary of a model right
so if we have a complex model in
computer vision we have convolutional
neural nets which make decisions that we
can't analytically find the decision
boundary for right so we don't know
which pixels need to be shifted in order
for this model to now classify this
image as a different category compared
to what it is right now and so what we
can do instead is we can use two
different approaches one is heuristics
and one is approximate posteriors and
I'll quickly talk about both of them in
order to make this ranking so heuristics
are generally based on continuous model
output so if we have a convolutional
neural network which is classifying the
Emnes data set which is just some
handwritten digits and the challenge is
usually to classify it as one of the
digits between 0 and 9 and then we make
a prediction with the model so we call
doc predict on this number down here on
this 5 and then we get this output right
and this is the probability of each of
these digits so
is currently claiming that it is you
know giving or assigning this
probability to the number six and it's
assigning this probability to the number
zero and then we call the model on a
different number and in this case it's
assigning most of the probability to the
number four and very little to the other
numbers realize that actually took quite
a bad example because this is a five and
it's assigning nothing to the five foot
just imagine that it was the other way
around so now we've got a model and it's
telling us something about this data and
we don't know the the actual labels for
this data right now so how can we
distinguish between these two how can we
decide which one we want to label next
so one heuristic approach is to just
take the margin between the top and the
second-highest prediction and so in this
case for the number on the Left it's
between six and zero it's assigning some
probability of zero point two seven to
six
and 0.25 to zero and the difference
between those is zero point zero two and
four this number on the right that
difference is much larger because most
of the probability has been assigned to
the number four and so that's one way we
can rank the data right we know that the
model is relatively certain about the
image on the right because the
difference between those top two
predictions is very high and then
another approach is to take the entropy
of this categorical distribution and
again we can see that the entropy on the
left is much higher because it's
assigning a lot of probability to
different categories and on the right
it's very low because most of the
probability is in one category and so
again we can use this to rank the data
and decide which one to label and so
this is a fairly nice approach because
it works with any model that produces
probabilistic output right it works with
any model that gives some probability
for each category but sometimes we don't
actually want to use that and in
particular with neural networks often
your networks are way way too confident
about the data and they're not very well
calibrated and they're giving really
confident output for predictions that
are completely wrong and so that's not
nice and would not help us
decide what to label and so instead what
we want to hopefully end up with is
approximate posteriors and so now
instead of assigning one probability to
each category for one image we're
assigning a distribution of
probabilities so that's what we want to
end up with how can we actually do that
one way is to use Markov chain Monte
Carlo in order to get sort of
approximate posterior distributions but
that can be quite difficult you need
sort of fairly well-defined model and
it's often not that fast if you've got a
lot of data and so the other thing which
I work on a lot is approximate posterior
neural networks and two approaches here
there's lots of them but just two that I
wanted to highlight is if you're
training a network and it has some
probabilistic components like dropout
layers then you can actually use those
components in order to generate
distributions of output and so this is
known as Monte Carlo dropout where you
just make many many predictions for one
image but you change the units in the
network that you drop out at each point
and so that gives you a distribution of
output and similarly you could do you
could model the the weights and the
network using the samples from your
stochastic gradient descent
so usually we train a model and this is
the lost surface and we're kind of
trying to use gradient descent to arrive
at the minimum of this loss surface but
if we actually assume that this
stochastic gradient descent is somehow
exploring this posterior distribution
then we can take samples from along the
way and use that in order to produce you
know a probabilistic neural network
basically so that's just to two
approaches that I work with a lot and
that has been pretty successful cool so
I've given you sort of the the
background for active learning and I've
told you why it might be useful for you
but what you actually need to do to do
active learning in Python and just going
back to this circle and that we're
trying to sort of fit we first need to
label some data and in order to do that
we really
need a Python process that acts as a
back-end Brett and selects the data
loads it from some database for example
and maybe it also fits our model and
then we also need an interface or
front-end for this
labeling process because especially when
we're using images we need to show the
images to a user and they need to be
able to click a button that determines
its category and so this front-end is
just going to display that labeling UI
to our users so luckily we actually have
a really good framework for running a
Python process as a back-end and web
interface as a front-end right and
that's the Jupiter framework and I've
developed this library called
Superintendent which leverages that and
the sort of AI pi widgets framework
which is sort of matched Python objects
and JavaScript front-end objects that
allow you to interact between the front
end and the back end in order to do this
labeling and I'm just going to
demonstrate this so this is a Jupiter
notebook right a lot of people are
familiar with this it's a combination of
code and output and some markup that we
write around it and what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to load the MLS data set from
scikit-learn
and this is the digits that I showed you
on the slides earlier and what we want
to do is we want to classify these as
you know one of their digits between 0 &
9 but we don't have any labels right so
we need to start creating some labels
and so all I'm gonna do is I'm going to
use this class from superintendent to
generate the widget I'm gonna pass it
the features of this data which is just
the actual pixel values of this of this
image I'm gonna also because I know
these are the digits between between 0 &
9 I'm going to give it the options that
I want to have displayed in my framework
in my UI and when I do that and then
display this widget we've got a labeling
interface so now we're seeing the digits
and we've got the buttons in order to
classify this data and I can start
labeling it in the beginning it's quite
easy because they're actually ordered
so I can just hit all these buttons and
you can see the progress as we're going
through this data set and we're racing
ahead cool if I ever make a mistake I
can also undo it or skip one of the
images because maybe I can't recognize
what it is like this that three or nine
it's a nine cool and so now we've
assigned some labels to this data and I
can access that as an attribute in this
in this widget class where we've
assigned all of these labels this one we
skipped but we've got some some label
data now so we can start using that so
the next step in the active learning
circle is we need to train our model
right and we need to make predictions on
unlabeled data and I'm not going to talk
too much about this because there's a
huge amount of frameworks to do model
fitting in Python and you could probably
run a whole conference about that alone
but just one thing I wanted to highlight
is what superintendent makes a lot of
use of is this scikit-learn interface
for models where you have these fit and
predict methods on model classes that
are fairly uniform across different
types of models so we can do something
with logistic regression and we can do
the exact same thing with random forests
if we're using the scikit-learn sub
module of Keros we can just do that with
a neural network as well and similarly
for pi torch there's frameworks that
sort of construct this this interface
for neural networks as well and we just
always have to use these fit and predict
methods if we have our model to find and
so obviously for M nest the state of the
art at the moment is a linear logistic
regression so we can just import that
from scikit-learn
and we can fit our model using this dot
fit method and then we can start making
predictions on our data and just because
earlier I showed you that we need that
we need probability output of these
models we can use this probability
prediction method instead in order to
get this continuous output on how
confident our model is about our data
cool but then we actually want to bake
this into the labeling process right so
we want to have a sort of uniform circle
where we can do this entire process of
training model of making predictions
ranking the data and then labeling some
more data all in one go and similarly we
can do that and superintendent because
of the niceness of these interfaces we
can create a new widget I'm going to
take over the labels from the previous
widget so if you have some labels that
you've already generated you can just
pass them into super Intendant objects
and I'm gonna pass the model that we've
just changed this logistic regression
model and I'm gonna say that I want to
reorder using the entropy so what I
showed you earlier right the entropy of
the distribution of the model output and
so now we've got the same widget but
we've got this extra button up here
which we can use to retrain our model
periodically it will show us some
performance output of our model as well
using cross-validation and we can once
we do that reorder our data based on the
uncertainty of the model so I'm gonna
assign a few more labels and then
retrain our model we don't have enough
labels to do proper cross validation yet
so we're not evaluating that but we have
now reordered our data and we're now
seeing really you know less clear images
which is nice already and we're
exploring a space in the in the sort of
feature in the data set that the model
is as of yet pretty uncertain about so
clearly a lot of eighths
I think that's because we skipped the
eight earlier
cool and we can just keep doing that and
keep training our model okay great so
we've got that going so now I've showed
you how to do that how to do labeling
just using the tools that you already
know Jupiter notebooks widgets which are
pretty pretty common and work really
well and Jupiter notebooks models that
you're familiar with scikit-learn
my torch so now the question is how can
we scale this because what I was doing
here is fitting a fairly simple model
that is very quick to train the data was
pretty pretty straightforward as well
and I could just do that by myself
hitting the retrain button whenever I
want to reorder the data but in practice
you probably want to send out your
labeling tool to a bunch of people who
will do the labeling for you so that a
you get maybe less bias mistakes by the
same person and B you're just not doing
it all by yourself and getting bored so
how can we scale this process and so
what we really need to do for that is we
need to share some information in
between the labeling sessions right so
here I was running a Python process just
on my laptop is pretty hard to share the
information from that process with
somebody else's laptop who's running you
know who's also doing labeling on the
same data set just because it's hard to
tell them which points I've already
labeled it's hard to tell them what my
model is currently saying about the
unlabeled data etc and so ideally what
we want to do is run the model fit on a
separate server that also allows us to
scale that server arbitrarily so if
we're fitting a neural network we can
have a much bigger instance that has
some GPU power in order to do that and
then we want to just have a single
ranking of all the unlabeled data for
all labelers so that we're sort of not
wasting any energy labeling separate
labeling and data twice or labeling on
inefficiently for one of the labelers
and so the sort of framework looks a
little bit like this we were going to
use a database in order to manage this
queue of labels to generate and also to
store the data so that not everybody has
to have the data on the laptop we can
use a server in the top left in order to
run the model and add data whenever we
get new data in and then we can have a
bunch of people and bottom right doing
the labeling for us and I'll just
quickly show how I've done this in the
past in a really successful way using
docker and using tools called a tool
called wallah which is fairly new I
think but which basically takes a
jupiter notebook and displays it as just
a website without all the code
without having to run every sell
yourself in order to get to the output
and we're just going to manage the data
in a Postgres database so this here so
we've got what we want to do is we want
to run one script which actually does
the orchestration of this process for us
and this is this Orchestrator PI script
which basically will we're defining a
model here and what we're going to do is
create a database connection to a
Postgres instance into this database
called Superintendent and then we're
basically going to connect to this
database
I'm gonna do this with docker compose
that's what I had to do this while loop
because otherwise if the database
doesn't come up everything fails and
then we're just going to run this
orchestrate method on our widget so this
widget will never actually be shown to
anyone but because we're basically
defining a model in exactly the same way
as we were when we were doing it
interactively we can still use this
widget in order to sort of have all the
nice utilities of reordering the data
and fitting the model regularly we're
just going to say that we want this
model to be fitted every 30 seconds and
only when there's 10 new labels in the
database and so what we want to do is
run this script regularly and at the
same time we want to then run a user
interface for the label is to actually
start labeling and so what I have for
this is a a notebook which is a lot
thinner than the one I was using to
demonstrate the capabilities so all
we're going to do is import the same
widget but from the distributed sub
module of Superintendent and we're just
going to pass that same database
connection in and we're also going to
say which options we want to we want to
display to the user and then all we need
to do is actually display this widget
that's what this bottom cell does cool
and so the way we're going to do that is
using voix
and I'm going to run this using docker
compose I'm just to show you that it's
quite nice and easy to bring up the
database and general
the UI for everyone at the same time so
we're just gonna bring up a Postgres
database here and this is just a UI for
the database and then we're gonna run
one server for our notebook and this is
gonna use this docket image that has
voluntold
and basically mount this notebook that I
just showed you into a specific location
in the docker image and then at the same
time we're going to run one server which
runs this orchestrates good script so
we've got kind of a separation in
between these two and if we're doing
this on a cluster then we could split
the or divide the compute and evenly
between this and have a much bigger
server for the orchestration script cool
so this is all not very much code which
is kind of nice and it will allow us to
bring up bring up this these four
servers pretty quickly so I'm just going
to run this and this is going to start
the database server for us it's also
going to start the notebook server for
us so that's this purple one here
database is coming up and the
orchestration is already happening in
the background and so now I'm just gonna
have to wait for volar to come up which
i think will be on port 8080 six six
yeah there it is
and so that's a debug this cool at this
very simple notebook
which I just showed you is now displayed
as a website that doesn't have any of
the Associated code or anything else
sort of around it so we can run this or
we can send this URL if we were running
this on the web server to colleagues who
can do the labeling for us and as you
can see preparing this talk I've already
done some labeling so we're already
progressing quite a bit through this
data set and I can just keep going with
this now and in the background the
orchestration server is ordering the
data clearly at the moment fours are
needed in order to improve this model
and I don't even know and we can start
generating more data efficiently without
having to worry about training the model
ourselves or even defining the model and
yeah if we wanted to scale this up at
some point we could swap in the logistic
regression for a convolutional network
or whatever we want to use in order to
classify this data and that sort of yeah
makes everything a little bit easier for
the people we've used this really
successfully in the past my previous job
used this library in this way of
orchestrating these notebooks in a
really big image classification problem
we've also used this for time series
classification so showing a specific
sort of time series plot to people and
asking them whether this fits into one
of the categories that we had predefined
and wanted to distinguish between each
other and yeah it's fairly flexible
because it all uses the Jupiter
ecosystem that you're familiar with and
like hopefully cool so yeah you can you
can install this library and there's
documentation up online in particular
the deployment is fairly new so if you
if you want to try that out and let me
know how it's going then then definitely
do and yeah that's it from me thank you
very much
[Applause]
yeah cool so I'm a little bit early so
we've got a lot of time for questions if
you have any I think there's a
microphone or there will be a microphone
circulating in a second it it should be
it's not yet but one of the things that
I want to work on next yeah getting
multiple people to rate the same data
point or label the same data point and
then modeling the agreement between them
is definitely something that I want to
include in this because it's pretty
useful to do yeah I don't have a way of
doing that at the moment just because
the way that the database tables get set
up doesn't allow it at the moment and
there's like a little bit of extra
modelling work to do in terms of the
agreement so it's going to come but yeah
if you have any experience with that
then definitely contribute or let me
know or talk to me
No so this doesn't have a way built in
there obviously lots of ways of doing
that and at the moment that needs to be
handled by the user and you've got full
access to the sort of database once it's
created so you can actually inspect the
labels and fit whatever other model you
want in a in a separate script or
notebook or whatever but yeah that's not
included in this at the moment
unfortunately
yeah that's a really good question so
the ranking in general is deterministic
right so so the entropy of the
predictions will always be the same if
you have a deterministic model that
doesn't you know change that put between
different runs and that can be a problem
definitely because if your model is bias
then the ranking will be biased as well
and so the way we solve that here is
actually we have a shuffle proportion
where you can just specify I want this
number of data points to be shuffled
each time we create the ranking just so
that you still have some randomness and
hopefully can maintain a representative
sample yeah in general that's a problem
in active learning right because if
you're creating a data set
for a specific model to improve that
model maximally then you don't actually
know whether that model will also
transfer to other models and so that's
something that shuffling some of the
right priorities can achieve
very good question um that really
depends on the ecosystem so so the the
framework is fairly flexible in that you
can if you have okay I killed the
Jupiter server but if you have them if
you have some other way of displaying
the data that's not images and you can
actually use any widget that comes or
that interface as well with the IPO
widget library which is this one here in
order to display the data and get the
user to give input so I work a lot on
object detection in addition to image
classification and so getting some boxes
around parts of an image would be really
nice I haven't found a good way that
interfaces well with with superintendent
to do that yet and some point I was
planning to do that myself but it's
quite a lot of JavaScript work and I
don't know JavaScript that well so um
yeah not yet but yeah in general it's
pretty flexible
[Music]
yes so well that really depends on on
the business problem that you're trying
to solve so so if you just want to get
to some accuracy or some performance of
your model however you want to define
that then you can just run this until
you reach that point and and you've got
the labels now in order to test the
model and so you can do your splits and
off the data and stuff there's also you
can also just decide to terminate it
once you reach some plateauing effect of
the performance of the model and really
that's completely up to you so so we
haven't implemented any of that here but
you can you can do that yourself yeah
so
yes again that's really up to the user
and so that's not something where you
can just define some metrics a priori
for that and it really depends on the
cost of your labels the cost of your
retraining and how long it takes to get
new labels so if every time you want to
get a real label you have to drive out
to the desert and drill into the core of
the earth then obviously you don't want
to do that too often but if it's just
getting people to click some buttons
then maybe you want to rebalance that a
little bit and and you know get hundred
labels for every time you retrain the
model and yeah it's it's completely up
to the user to define that balance and
for us we basically rerun the model all
the time because we've got a lot of GPUs
sitting idle in Canada and so yeah
I have yeah and that's definitely on the
roadmap as well this sort of serving
notebooks as a website is a fairly new
thing that we're able to do and so I
haven't developed that in any depth
ideally what you would need for that is
to be able to parametrize the request to
the notebook depending on metadata from
Mechanical Turk and I don't think that's
implemented yet and for notebooks and at
some point I was thinking about maybe
implementing a different front-end for
this that use this is something like
flatly - or something where you have a
proper web server but I think what
people really want is to be able to
switch very easily from the notebook -
to the labeling session and so so we
haven't done that yet
[Applause]